moi j'ai l'habitude de tout vous dire
mais là et j'ai un truc qui me turlupine
depuis ce matin merde
je suis pas bien je vous cache pas que
je me suis réveillé j'étais en ni norme
aura sera j'ai une espèce
se sont magiques c'est vrai je le dis
aux téléspectateurs une grosseur change
pas une grosse heure ninon cesse chaque
j'ai une espèce d'excroissances ici
et delphine me dit que c'est parce que
j'ai fait trop de sport et cinéma séries
lancées mardi l'hôpital le journal d'une
hernie inguinale voilà un canal d'une
kunal mais voilà qui est du queensland
c'est quoi ça et en fait quand on fait
trop de sport au bout d'un moment ça
pète et donc il ya l'intestin qui va
sortir leur haut niveau
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi
3 du coup c'est cyril c'est votre nom
c'est votre intestin qui vient de percer
votre abdomen décidé l'arrêt de ses
shows est-ce que c'est chaud ils
s'étaient amoncelées pouilloux session
ici c'est rouge parce que c'est chaud et
vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît au sepa depuis mika est ce que
c'est quoi ce que c'est quoi excusez moi
je vous déjà eu ça allait avoir papa
c'est médical 1 à l'attention de ses
pairs d'échographie de la main j'ai sa
passion attention vous n'avez pas
laisser faire ça si ça va pas nous c'est
médical
c'est que vous êtes cette docteure anne
bécheau comment cela était pas que vous
aviez pas du tout à ça mais si pas du
tout si c'est pas le sport j'ai beaucoup
de muscu jamais une troisième couilles
il
ya très peu les jambes je vous ai même
travail que c'est pas vrai s'est bâti je
vous le dis alors là c'est pas vrai lane
alors je vous le dis à mon avis c'est
con quand je joue quand je fais comme ça
ce n'est pas docteur pas ce que je vais
faire les noirs d'afrique aux goûts et
souple et à tout le monde de se taire je
veux une compensation entre delphine et
moi on savoir si vous voulez que ce
serait peut-être meilleure des choses
pour les pattes je suis stressé ça va
mais sans regret savait pas alors
j'aimerais est ce que vous voulez que
j'appelle mon médecin en direct bah oui
puis ouais parce que ça peut être aussi
une tumeur cancéreuse
le week end en
navarre et avec ça alors non alors germé
alors mon père c'est délicat qui veut
dire quoi j'ai mal à la tâche bannon de
pigeons il veut dire hernie mais arrête
tes c'est pas un peu plus foncée plus à
rien ne doit aller au beau frère il est
heureux logue qui tombent aux frères
bats les rôles org check in et séguy
c'est un médecin frère bah oui c'est le
premier mari messenger sa vie ah bah oui
donc un beau frère
c'est tout ça c'est parce que cyril fait
trop de ce paquet et roger la même chose
il a dû se faire opérer parce qu'il
avait une grosse harrison à la balle au
bond c'est ce que tu as comme l a dit et
vieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les amène à moi j'ai la maladie j'ai par
la meute améliorer ses couleurs sans
déconner attendu tient plus à l'état je
tapais simon pedneault rajoutez pas s'il
vous plaît les noms n'ont
[Applaudissements]
jamais dit dieu
j'ai demandé s'il vous plaît me fait
plaisir parce que vous m'envoyez
personnes âgées peuvent
faire
du mal à décoder glacée
mais je dois
aller
[Applaudissements]
des maladies d'avant jésus-christ la
chambre sera la
polio allait prendre une glace allait
prendre un truc excuse moi est-ce que
l'érection fonctionnent encore
de canal mais non on est sur canal non
mais doit ce que je remets toi aussi tu
sors tu me fais chier
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui ont des bonnes nouvelles à aa
lemon way c'est une blessure d'un
sportif de haut niveau oui les
footballeurs ont souvent ça
prouve que vous êtes un sportif de haut
niveau il va s'agir de ça vous avez plus
simple entre rester
moi je pense que c'est ce qui a été
coupée qui repousse à côté
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle mon médecin mais vous êtes
vraiment angoissé mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai on avait peur de tout ça vous
êtes un peu hypocondriaque tellement là
bien sûr qu'à toi qui me connaît bien
mais je vois pas ce que vous mettez
toujours du gel et vous le faites super
hâte au mali on vous l'a dit je voulais
que pas nous fâcher
[Applaudissements]
japan on met ça
s'appelle mon message le pape et mon
père parce que là c'est délicat mon père
ce héros pour les très gros dossier
c'est quand j'avais perdu une couille
dans la rue la vapeur
il me répond pas ce qu'on
je vais l'appeler dans deux secondes est
d'abord un vrai c'est pas grave du coup
vous avez jamais rien de grave est en
bas de santé quoi vous êtes sûr ouais
ouais moi jeunesse que c'est pourquoi on
sait qu'on est en bonne santé est ce que
quand vous marchez là comme ça où ça
départ est ce que vous avez mal
[Applaudissements]
ça passe reprise est un geste de padel
un truc un peu dans l'extension
vous le sentez vous le chantez un peu
des filles à quoi qui me reçoit aussi un
peu des fourmis l'on met pas des
fourmillements et fourmillements dans sa
gratte au bout ça chatouille non ça fait
rien de tout ça non ya pas de forme ion
alors sachez par expérience vous
rentrerez le matin à l'hôpital petite
opération un petit filet on rentre ça et
l'après midi vous êtes dehors c'est en
deux heures
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec deux mika et ça un petit massage
avec de l'arnica vous restez vous qu'est
ce que vous avez à dire mais quelques
recherches sur doctissimo si vous avez
une troisième mi-temps avant de pousser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon médecin me dit je t'appelle plus
tard qu'est ce que je fais je dis je
suis à l'antenne j'aimerais te parler
assure jean quand même une antenne j'ai
envie de parler chez mal à lachenaie qu
est ce que vous comptez jouer ce week
end bah je joue là oui je jouais des
lois doit j'ai mal à lachenaie qu'il va
pas comprendre que cette lachenaie que
mons part
j'ai mal à la jeunesse bon
je suis pas bien merci en tout cas kévin
et carla d'être la seule
un jour alors que je vous reçois la peur
au ventre mais je
me geraldine me connaissez je suis
énormément votre belle fille combien
j'en voyais attentes et parle avec vous
ainsi pas ouais merci défi merci
heureusement que tu es là
je travaille au tex mex après moi
non mais oui car est ce que je peux vous
réconforter oui avec grand plaisir
pour vous c'est quoi j'ai un cadeau pour
vous c'est quelqu'un qui l'a fait pour
vous à saint-etienne non c'est de la
pyrogravure ces voix là vous pourrez le
match
c'est très bon et si vous
c'est tout partait à l'hôpital vous
pourrez le mettre sur votre table de
chevet
ah
ah salut
[Applaudissements]
c'est vachement beau jeu pour le mettre
là et ressemblant surtout non mais c'est
vrai c'est très ressemble pas c'est très
beau merci leschi riches sinon mais je
vous jure carey qui remonte je reçois
des amis aujourd'hui et vous avez la
sienne qui a dit ça alors vous est-ce
que vous avez pris votre température qui
a dit sa quête d'une j'avais de fiel
vous avez
presque à un médecin dans le public
je m'en doutais chanter que personne et
ratissaient je voyais bien que personne
ne sait ce qu'un médecin là à côté s'il
vous plaît j'aimerais qu'on aille ya pas
médecin à côté là dans le truc
j'aimerais qu'on trouve un médecin genre
à la foule
je plais voilà trouver un médecin qui
viennent il va m'examiner je suis pas
bien sinon j'ai pas pouvoir faire cette
émission je vous jure que c'est vrai je
change soit une excroissance comme une
espèce voilà c'est là c'est là entre
l'ado et la gencive que les bactéries
attaque
c'est bon on va voir un médecin arrive à
nos instincts pas qu'un diplôme de
médecin dans l'équipe d'ailleurs il
n'est pas qu'un diplôme de médecin de
l'équipe ah non non non il n'a pas qu'un
diplôme non plus 3 sur 6
c'est une belle soirée crois vraiment
que sur les versions étaient médecins on
sera chez elle vit en exil soir
franchement non mais franchement
voilà jean michel cohen
kevin et carla je veux revenir dans ses
restaurants la mif mais là je suis papa
by des nutritionnistes vous donner un
petit conseil d'éthique jean ziegler
touch apple esthétique de castaldi
apparemment jean michel cohen et au
cours de mon mes problèmes barande des
randonnées tout cela
si je dois mourir j'espère que vous
soyez tous au courant
que vous avez écrit un testament
alors je vais voler à mach justement on
va en parler
qui aimeraient quoi alors sans avoir de
mauvaise nouvelle les niveaux je connais
un
vrai-faux d'animateur c'est vrai que du
coup ils aimeraient bien ta place ouais
c'est pas du testament exactement qu'est
ce qu alors qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
avec des bots barre si haut si on doit
prendre des mauvaises nouvelles me
concernant au québec la disco c'est bon
c'est pas aujourd'hui on siffle
rien alors qu'est-ce que match de l'en
but qu'est ce que j'aimerais oui
récupérer la case la case de 19h ce sera
mon fils un père en fils bino il est
même pas majeur et bail alors ce sera la
tipp et berlin comme ça c'est jean
michel cohen qui m'appellent un
quoi
jean-michel de cyril hanouna
tu m'a rappelé je pouvais pas répondre
vas-y que je la fais une troisième coupe
jean michel tu n'appelles je suis à
l'antenne
et c'est un homme meurtri qui t'appelle
tu
agis je m'attends au pire non je te fais
pas pour parler de nutrition quoi que ce
soit
mais j'ai mal jean-michel
tête aux pieds non à lachenaie qu
la petite la grosse non je vais
t'expliquer gino douleur tu vois il
paraît que c'est sur c'est quoi la nonne
l'aide au niveau de la glisse le coach
était que je fais beaucoup de sport j'ai
une douleur à la gueule et j'ai comme
une petite excroissance bull n'ont pas
une bonne âme et excroissance mais
accueillis en a3 maintenant
je raccroche
jean-michel je ne te cache pas que je
suis un poil inquiet est ce que tu
pourrais c'est grave
oui je pense que oui
j'ai lu un truc sur toi tu as raconté
dans un journal que tu étais tu allais
être célibataire pendant deux ans oui
c'est peut-être ça la raison de ce choix
c'est un principe
mais ça c'est dr l'homme
a un truc de l'homme bonjour donc c'est
pas grave tu es sûre non tirées et
examine et inquiète tu es sûr mais ce
que je dois mettre quoi tu crois
un peu de pommade voilà ah oui mais je
la mets moi-même non je collais met sa
dépendent pour nourrir et d'intimité
avec certaines n'étaient chroniqueuse
situé
au coeur aux couleurs s'est doublée
ouais ok ça avait commencé à tomber
amoureux alors qui est prêt à me
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis sportif malien n'a qu'un
jeu sports a une c'est lui qui n'a qu'un
jeu mais les symboles faut bien bien
faire pénétrer lors delphine
faire confiance je suis qui a rien rien
de sûr chez nous n'ont en revanche ce
que je vais vous dire c'est une bonne
nouvelle si la boule vient de sortir
incessamment sous peu peut-être qu'en
allant jusque chez l'ostéo il peut
vouloir enfoncer drainé tu peux les
faire confiance à les auxiliaires de vie
c'est que juste après match et l'ostéo
devait faire je peux demander un truc je
vais dire un truc qui jamais dit à
personne au quai
des films à partir d'aujourd'hui tu
seras ma responsable sentais
bien je prends la mission très à coeur
al hajja roger 1
très important et là-dessus faudra
repasser parce que c'est vrai que vous
adorez les pattes arrabiata les pas de
sauce tomate mais il n'y a pas beaucoup
de légumes dans votre alimentation déjà
passé au niveau du sort c'est ok mais je
pense que ça c'est soit vous avez fait
trop de sport soit c'est aussi la
maladie effectivement des célibataires
quand on a trop de goût d'action voilà
on peut aussi se craque et cette zone là
rapport sexuel on peut craquer leur
série ce côté là alors allez-vous j'ai
fait ça pour le boire oui allez-y
c'est pas ça mais par hazard et comme
ceci oui mais des mecs comme ça tu
paddon se divertir ou la jolla
franchement les mecs s'il vous plaît je
suis extrêmement qui est tout le monde a
l'air de prendre ma maladie ouais par
dessus la jambe alors défini merci des
films si t'es pas là d'un dictateur en
place
une vraie question amical je vais pas
tout vous dire je vais vous dire qui me
remplacera t des bananes à dix les ja je
peux vous le dire ce ne sera pas
quelqu'un qui sifflent bernard montiel
normale normale ce qui l'a le 6 à 7 bien
sûr non
tu fais toujours servi toi non il peut
avoir le 6 à 7 non ce sera pas
permanente et next je veux quelqu'un de
vigo
sa luge en tout cas
écarté puisse garder la casse pendant
des années des années
jamais la vérité demande de zinc
chaleureusement ouais non qu'est ce qui
se passe ce ne sera pas vous parce que
vous avez le 6 à 7 lundi voici mais les
foi ont combien
je veux dire c'est celui qui me
remplacera à partir de lundi c'est
simple c'est clair c'est net à lundi ce
sera mon chéri wee bb ben c'est normal
chez animateurs tu es libre lundi oui eh
bien tu seras le chroniqueur de delphine
[Applaudissements]
m
ce sera ma responsable santé il
remplacera si éventuellement je dois
passer l'armé à gauche ce week end
ça sert à beaucoup à qui ça ferait
plaisir hein je vous donnerai des
nouvelles heure par heure ce week-end
bien entendu thierry lespiaucq pour
venir à l'essentiel le testament c'est
vous
je vais vous dire qu'ils devaient la
maison de los angeles bon je vais le
petit petit bleu petit pied-à-terre je
vais noté parce que la maison de los
angeles s'il vous plaît pas encore toi
le jacuzzi
dur à dire quelques raquettes de padel
temps sur dix doigts 3 parce que je vais
faire cet homme mort ce week-end vous
mais non mais vous passerez pas la main
gauche la mauvaise graine dur touama me
répond
mais j'arrive pas à l'obtenir donc
je sais oui les 19 porsche
même 18 ça m'irait si vous avez signé
votre fils et filles ok oui le zodiaque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je ne veux rien sauf un bon souvenir
de vous
[Applaudissements]
et
bien moi après avoir pris soin de vous
je prendrai soin de votre petite chienne
uns s'équipent banyala plusieurs
après avoir entendu si
je suis en mesure de vous dire ce que je
vais légué est acquis
le jacuzzi ce sera effectivement pour
guillaume genton persil ou une grande
valeur sentimentale je sens plus
dessiner géraldine maillet je voulais
gré tout mes raquettes de paddle génial
matthieu delormeau
je voulais gré
des porsche
des portes et
je m'en veux pas c'est à dire tout le
mal à des portes voilà d'accor
gilles verdez
remercie
je vous la great où les portes les deux
mois qui ont été faits en marche et le
besoin de gars t'as dit l'autre jour et
le blouson de castaldi de l'autre jour
également
parrain castaldi connexion des bd de
toutes vos émissions pour qu'ils
apprennent comment la dre je voulais
grésil et de diack à wil à gré le dvd
des deux saisons deux autres attaques
ce sera pour moi
bernard montiel
je voulais gré
toutes mes crèmes de beauté
c'est vrai je sais que la dame chez
les jeunes évidemment alors il ya la
mienne oui c'est vrai que ma mère vous
utilisez encore cette crème sûre d'elle
mais c'est une blague ou non adéquat et
d'histoire d'abord faire une très belle
et très bien la crème tutu il aura
peut-être utilisent tous les matins une
petite crème et delphine sabatino ajouté
paris semble oui ça me fait tout le
reste delphine voilà 13 mai 27 bateaux
40 ces immeubles droits inclus va être
content à bassorah pour vous et roger au
présent
bon sinon elle a aura pas un jour qui
passera sans qu'on pensera à vous et
soyez gentil gentil pour nous fait pas
un johnny qu'on vous en terre pas à six
mille bornes ou dix mille bornes je peux
avoir un enterrement assez simple niveau
avion et tout cv sera surtout un bas
fond reste nous reste inquiète pas je
vais manger ce midi je vois ce qui reste
que je n'ai rien
merci oui en attendant vous devriez
demander une poche de glace pour la
venue pour la poser sur la zone qui met
le saura pas mais s'il
n'est pas exclu des mêmes sans mourir